[Música]
y llegó el momento de revista de prensa
ya está lista conmigo en el estudio rosa
pérez más de rosa bienvenida feliz
viernes ya fin de semana rosa abrimos
esta sección con una serie audiovisual
que hizo el 'new york times' sobre el
sistema global de alimentos y sus
implicaciones e implicaciones rosa
bastante interesante lo que vamos a ver
a continuación eso es raro las imágenes
que hemos seleccionado pues algunas son
un poco fuertes porque este especial
sobre como comentabas del sistema global
de alimentos se divide en tres partes en
un primer lugar sobre los impactos
medioambientales de la agroindustria que
tal y como recuerda este reportaje
responsable de un tercio de las
emisiones de efecto invernadero a nivel
global y es uno de los lobbies más
fuertes de capitol hill pero nos hemos
querido fijar en imágenes que pedimos a
nuestros compañeros que nos pinchen
ahora cuando puedan sobre las
implicaciones en términos de maltrato
animal de hecho tal y como señalan los
periodistas que narran esta pieza es muy
difícil acceder dentro de las granjas
industriales de hecho estas imágenes las
siguen a través de la asociación merci
animales mercy for animals y bueno son
muy explícitas una de las claves para
entender por qué se llegan a producir
este tipo de imágenes es porque pues son
de hecho los grandes grupos industriales
los que controlan todos el proceso de
crecimiento de crianza de los pollos de
hecho distintos a granjeros
particularmente uno kerry que testifica
en este reportaje explica cómo están
completamente sujetos a las demandas de
productividad de la agroindustria que
son pues entre otras pilgrim's o tysons
no tal y como menciona este reportaje
señalan los periodistas que un 5 por
ciento de los pollos llegan a morir
antes de llegar al matadero ya sea por
ataques al corazón porque están
exhaustos la forma tan artificial que
tienen de engordar los provoca que
lleguen a no poder soportar su propio
peso y que mueran de ataques al corazón
de deshidratación o de distintas
enfermedades raúl y como comentábamos
los bajos precios a los que es
proporcionado lo que es ofertado el
pollo finalmente los supermercados y en
las cadenas de alimentación provoca que
los granjeros no puedan competir con
esta agroindustria y que tengan que
subyugar senos a este poder finalmente
piden grandes créditos para poder
alcanzar las exigencias de productividad
lo que se les requiere y no pueden salir
de este sistema y finalmente hemos
querido señalar también el tercer
capítulo de este especial que propone la
ingesta de insectos como alternativa
nutricional y bien yo no sé revol si
estás probado los insectos alguna vez sí
los he probado sí que te ha parecido que
depende de cómo los frían y los razones
son como soldaditos como un chicharrón
algo así
de hecho la antropóloga julie lesnik
comenta en este reportaje que es la
cultura y no el gusto lo que define lo
que es comestible uno y según naciones
unidas dos mil millones de personas en
el mundo es decir un tercio de la
población mundial pues incluye los
insectos en su dieta diaria y de hecho
señalan el ejemplo de la langosta como
pasó de ser una comida con muy poca
digamos categoría a puede ser una
exquisitez hoy en día incluso provee a
los chapulines en méjico en este último
viaje que fui citar en en diciembre rosa
cambiamos radicalmente de tema nos
fijamos sobre una entrevista de celia
castellano a bombay minich el ex locutor
de radio sarajevo una conversación donde
él narra su rol como periodista durante
la guerra de bosnia de la que se cumplen
30 años este año 2022 así es y en esta
conversación el locutor de radio
sarajevo explica que cuando estalló la
guerra al principio pensaban que iba a
durar unas dos semanas pero que de
cuatro programas que tenía la radio todo
se redujo a uno que duraba 24 horas dijo
que él no entrevistaba a comandantes ni
a políticos porque no se sentía cómodo
porque no creía lo que decían y que en
su lugar inventó programas sobre cómo
sobrevivir o sobrellevar la pérdida de
familiares para los que invitaba pues a
psicólogos
tras como sobrevivir en los subterráneos
donde se refugiaba la gente durante este
largo sitio a sarajevo de hecho explica
que uno de sus programas más populares
se llamaba lazos rotos bueno una de las
secciones porque tal y como cuenta el
titular a veces pasaba 24 horas o 40 en
la radio se llamaba lazos rotos y
trataba de poner en contacto a familias
que se habían perdido durante la guerra
dice una vez me preguntó me preguntó una
familia que había pasado pues con otros
miembros y dice que estaban en bosnia
oriental donde ocurrieron cosas
terribles como la matanza de sbrenica no
sé cómo a través de los exiliados me
avisaron de que 12 miembros de esa
familia fueron encerrados en un campo de
concentración y de que seis de ellos
habían muerto tardé varios días en poder
decírselo fue durísimo por otro lado
también comenta el locutor a la
periodista a celia castellano que nunca
ha pensado bueno que ha asumido ya que
nunca va a poder volver a sarajevo rosa
gracias entonces por toda la información
que damos pendientes con un tema para el
día lunes el poder de los planes los que
leyeron las cárceles venezuela dentro
del béisbol de las grandes ligas de ese
país rosa muchísimas gracias